>> THEY HAVE THE HALFWAY AND TH
GEEKIE.
THEY THROW IT TO NOT OUT.
THEODORE PLAYS IT NO TO WENNBER
COUNTER ON A POTENTIAL TWO ON
ONE AND OUTSTANDING KRAKEN
AND FORCING ONE TO ALEXA.
ONE OFF TOTHERE AND JOHAN
SON BACK HANDER OFF OF THE SIDE
OF THE NET HELPED ME TO
GET TO THAT POINT.
>> LOOKING
DOWN NOT THE BERLIN
THE
SCENE OF THE NET AND OF ONE ABO
BICEPS AND
GOT A LONG ROAD AHEAD BUT IT IS
>> JOHNNY
JAYDEN SCHWARTZ.
>> 8 MINUTES WITHOUT A SHOT JOB
THATLING PUSH, PADDLE DOWN   AN
STRAIGHTAWAY TO LAUZON AND JOE
HANSSEN.
LEHNER GOESOF BY TANEV.
GETTING TO SHOT FROM THE THE
POINT. HAVE OFFENSIVE ZONE TIME
MESSAGE SENT AND RECEIVED.
A ONE-TIMER POWER PLAY
HOME AT HOME FOR THE MIDDLE.
GREAT BUMP PASS.
OVER TO
OFFICIAL.
>> SHOOTERS, IF THEY SEE A GOAL
GETTING BEAT, THEY WILL KEEP
T.
IT IS CHIPPED OUT.
ANOTHER AT